thank you for watching hella opinions
where we talk all things black culture
news and entertainment please be sure to
comment below and let me know what you
think about the show thanks
[Music]
welcome to hella opinions your home for
black news culture and entertainment yep
we're talking to all black everything
over here okay
I'm Sylvia Oh bail and with us today are
Brooklyn's own main oh hey which reports
Taylor Brooks Busby's own Jameer pawn
and comedian banda Carlos hey ole this
will be talking situation shift how many
years seven seven years of bad sex
Wow Ameno gotta look at people I'm just
trying to make something so today we're
drinking with today we're drinking so
where are we
whiskey sours oh we're we're talking
situation ships a little bit later in
the show
all right yes but for now let's dig into
some foolishness
first of all single little mo says she
isn't quite here for Queen not just
performance on the Soul Train Awards
light-skinned girl que tweeted no cat I
didn't even know who love mo was before
I saw love in hip-hop furthermore I
didn't even know she had music Queen can
blow period she is hating way too much
now as hard as it is to maybe trust
anybody's opinion who said I don't know
whole lot more words you love in hip-hop
because she locked me at that point of
the tweet what do you guys think about
the whole little Mo's comments on Queen
Naja so Train Awards performance who saw
the soul/psyche I thought you didn't see
it okay that's oh what I saw her singing
my first thought was okay
add another riff to the riff to the riff
to the restroom
he was riffing on top of the risk let's
look back to Beyonce and little Moe I
will say this I get what Queen Naja was
saying about your vet in a game maybe
you can encourage me I would love to
know where I could get voice lessons God
what she said what I said it in my way
but that's how I interpreted it was she
said and with little Moe I think maybe
she could have cut her comments down in
half because it started out like hey
okay and then it just went left okay
okay yeah because you know Queen Naja to
your point she spent basically like for
the vets you guys don't know how many of
us grew up looking up to you you don't
know how you may kill our dreams by
cutting us down that yes
but little mall had a point about
exposure meaning more than talent
perhaps as far as who was casted for the
cypher Raige Amir do you have thoughts
on that yeah yeah no no I'm a green I
mean if we look at the ciphers before in
the past I mean they they had a nice
mixture of people and always Ledisi and
Eddie Levert and Casey from Jodeci like
I know what they were trying to do like
make a nice little blend and that's cool
but if you want a cypher no matter
whether you riffing or you rapping you
gotta you got to bring it bring it you
gotta bring it you gotta bring it and I
think there's also this thing about the
difference between YouTube stars which
is a new thing for R&B extent and then
like stars who came up the traditional
way many ways anybody you know what you
know what it's it's hard for people that
come up the traditional way to kind of
get used to the way the things are now
cuz you got people that's actually
celebrities off of social media and
stuff like that so when you look at it
it's like then well how are you famous
so it's like it is what it is though we
got to embrace it but it but here's
another thing you got to be careful what
you say because it almost anything that
you say can be construed as hate yeah
and I think I always think the things
versus like being authentic versus being
inauthentic and sometimes I think okay
did you post it on social media because
you wanted to see the reaction of other
people or because you came
about what Queen Ida thought because
people forget hey you can call her you
can text her but you posted it so that
everybody else could see what you
thought and that's kind of the issue
that I have whenever somebody feels like
they went to social media to give their
opinion it's like you really just wanted
the reaction to your opinion and that's
what I felt like with that comment but
what you guys are saying about YouTube
and Instagram and Twitter we get caught
up and feeling like just because
something was how it used to be means
that how it should be but like who's to
say they're like some Instagram and
Twitter aren't someplace I get what LUMO
is saying cuz LUMO came up into this
world
like you have to work you have to
especially be good yeah whereas in a
microwave age of the internet and social
media you might not have to be that good
no you might not but between nas's
points she's like no I am good and I
want to be better help me be better yeah
it's not at fault that she coming up in
this in this age right so yeah you can
have all this talent and then it could
be an artist that just does something
something crazy that goes viral and
everybody just jumps right behind it
right and then you can't gauge you this
talent but it is what it is like Kim
Kardashian is little celebrity mm-hmm so
that we want we gonna be mad at up
because she's a celebrity that she
doesn't have talent yeah this is just
the time we live in in like the time it
is what it is we have to embrace it
because when you don't embrace it you
look old you are embracing it Lomo
because you're on social media well
let's so let's also tuck it in the in
the theme of crazy times that we're
living in Takashi 6-9 pleaded not guilty
to federal racketeering and gun charges
on Monday King Royale gave a shout out
to power with this tweet the only person
that could beat the case for Takashi
[Applause]
[Laughter]
even got jokes that have a lot of profit
avi what do you what was your reaction
to the Takashi arrests and at first they
were saying he was in a very dangerous
prison then they were saying that he was
moved to a slightly less yeah like what
were your thoughts when he got arrested
and all that I thought it immediately he
was going Saanich I was like he's about
to pull the wig off and he
in this world he's just playing and he's
not a gang member
he's just an entertainer payment
business I'm trying to figure out why
they were recording him on that FaceTime
calling on time oh yeah wait he said I
got it I got you an IG live ordering a
hit on somebody it's funny to some
people yeah
but he's in a real situation yeah yeah
like understand what I'm saying like
he's in a real situation so you know the
memes is cool and all that my background
I come from background like that you
know and a half you know I come from
that so I understand I'm a brother
that's in federal custody right now so
it's not a game like eat this is a
wake-up call for him and not only is it
a wake-up call for him I believe it's a
lot of weight it's a wake-up call for a
lot of young artists coming up in this
game thinking that they need to do
anything you know and create this type
of energy just to get likes just to get
views just to go viral and in and it's
not even about selling albums no more
it's about being accepted because we we
what do we do now we we judge and we
measure love with likes mmm right so now
[ __ ] is doing anything for follow us
and didn't we not that we didn't we
should have learned a lesson with Biggie
and Tupac but even with xxx right it's
all about what the the energy that you
put out there is gonna come back to you
right and unfortunately and in his
situation that negative energy started
coming back to him and he got killed
when he was making a change like hey let
me put some positive stuff out there but
that negative energy started coming back
so hopefully it is a wake-up call for
other people in artists especially like
how about just focus on your talent yeah
cuz he's in a tough situation right now
care who you is right now and I'm I'm
assuming I don't know that they got him
segregated right now he might be locked
in and mentally they breaking them
this is real yeah I mean prison is
definitely no joke and you know there's
been a lot of talk about the role the
media is playing
Jumeirah in this I I think that like
there's talk about it but I also think
it's very important to bring up the fact
that like with xxx and Takashi
they both had sexual abuse cases before
and many of this right you know Takashi
was on pro plea deal for and the child
sex allegation to happen against him and
now part of that was to not get any more
trouble and now he has but jamia do you
think that the media is doing a good job
per train the whole story of what's
going on here or do you think that
people are just focusing on like I said
the funny part of it or like even just
the fact that oh if he snitching or not
well I definitely think like the media
is playing this part much like what
happened with Biggie and Tupac media
loves controversy so they have this
character that's polarizing that's
getting in trouble that's been putting
out all this crazy energy and what
they're doing is like they're going re
eating up every story everything that we
hear from jail oh he got sick he got
separated from general pop he's in
protective custody he's going to snitch
she's not going to sin she's not looking
at people you know so these my new
details that are coming out because he's
so polarizing and so hot right now
they just eaten it all up as opposed to
telling a grand scale story I agree I'm
like the media loves characters and I
think that Takashi has kind of made
himself a character and he's so loud and
he has this big energy not saying
anything is wrong with that but when you
almost become a caricature of yourself
it's easier for people to like
dehumanize you right and say like of
course you're doing this because it's
not right right but because of like the
persona that he has it has made people
covered the story differently and that's
wrong I'm not excusing it but I think
that that is the reasoning as to why
it's covered that way yeah so your
mother here human right now though yeah
are you human
yeah absolutely hopefully he'll he and
other apples were learned from his
situation
next up actress Gina Rodriguez stepped
into it with this comment last week
watch petrified in this space talking
about
equal pay especially when you look at
the intersectional aspect of it right
where white women get paid more than
black women and black women get paid
more than Asian women Asian women get
paid more than Latino women and it's
like a very scary space to step into did
you guys see this clip yeah what was
tailing what was your using your gas
because every time it gets me every time
and not even because I feel like she's
entirely coming from a very malicious
place but I do think it's you know kind
of becoming a pattern of Gina's to push
aside the trials of black women you know
right now so Sofia Vergara is making
more money on TV than Tracee Ellis Ross
and when the other black extra that's
what I was gonna say did she have fact
checkers out on this one yeah and I
think that's a big issue that you can
say something and then nobody says
anything like the Forbes list or your
Vergara is the highest carry Washington
is like the only black woman at number
eight right so and I agree I do not
think that Gina was in any way being
malicious but we get into the space we
think that to talk about the US we have
to talk about the me and that's not
always the right thing because if you
want to then start separating women of
color you're taking away from the whole
conversation of just color in general
and we saw Gina do this and she was
talking to yar out yep and yeah it went
like when yar is asked okay you're such
a good representation for black woman
and Gina goes no just women it's like
with me I said what I said when I said
when I said it lack women because yes
you know you love being this role model
for women like that's a big honor but
black women do not have somebody to look
at yeah and so when you aren't seeing
yourself in that space you feel like you
have to separate yourself and that's
really I think dangerous to continue to
do that and I just seems actually
continues to like the way she talks
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Kristiana tweeted Gina Rodriguez is why
you won't see me standing under the
women of color umbrella anytime soon
a lot of women of color despise black
women but have found a convenient tool
to advance it advance their own agenda I
think that's true
it's because I retailer was saying
separating people of color like we all
enter race together so that I don't need
to throw me under the bus right got to
do that black women are in the same spot
as even maybe further back then a lot of
women of people of color like a lot of
people of color so we just have to
adjust our mindsets she said some very
anti black statements in the past child
says Ella we talked about the interview
that she did with Yara but she has to
find a medium cuz it's not us that's
preventing you from getting the money
you know if anything you get the context
of what someone is saying when they say
of black women yeah because would you
have that same opinion and if if the
comment was directed to Harvard say oh
you are a great representation of Latina
women right well she has stop then you
know you get the context of it and again
get your fact checkers out were you
talking about your personal salary right
you're not making the same amount
because like the the what's the actress
Sophia Vergara you can maybe she needs
that's like a history lesson to
understand that you can't separate
Latino from black right because I was
gonna say that right this is what I'm
saying we all come from African descent
so we all we all really want people and
then the ghetto was really no difference
like growing up you got Spanish people
living right next door mm-hmm
like what's really different we go
through the same struggle yeah go
through the same pain so she needs to
maybe have a history lesson and
understand that she really can't women
of color meaning all of us
all women of color black Latino like
it's all the same thing yeah and I feel
like black women are always advocating
for all women of color right but women
aren't necessarily always advocating for
black women that is a fact yeah yeah
that's what that looks like that's a
good point and that point on because and
that's why you that's why she's a god
well congratulations are in order for
Juelz Santana and his boo because wait
for it he finally put a ring on it
waited until his yeah and what do you
think of being misunderstood about his
choice they were posted Kimbella
with now which is why people are seeing
like post prime is what I think the
nicer way of like the post prime they're
trying to say like you know Juelz
there's not that hot like it's not he
gives facing criminal charges they're
talking about you know his dental
situation he's in a really tough spot
which I don't think it's fun to make fun
nice to make fun of but I think they're
talking about the moment in which he
chose to propose is when he's the most
like hard going through right now so
what so what we our people love love us
so what's the difference but he chose to
to to to to marry her five six years ago
what was the difference if she loves him
she with him like what's the difference
the people that's doing the most talking
is the people that's doing a less living
right now I I agree with what you're
saying I do but dis oblate that was out
of a kid go ahead dude I think the thing
is well why didn't she deserve him when
he wasn't there but they was did
together but they were they weren't his
wife so what man that's the thing though
right we get we get caught up too much
in cities titles they were in a
relationship like a married couple
already okay but here's the cuz I lived
it okay let's talk about it really
I'd lived it in I suffered through it I
was in a relationship for ten years and
when we were about to get married he
died one month prior to our what he
dates here's what I learned because we
were a lot of people in our culture
don't know what does what does the
government have to do what does a piece
of paper or title have to do with our
love and yes I agree with that but when
it comes down to it if something happens
you could say that's your wife all day
but that's what the government do have
something to say about it you could lose
your home you could lose everything you
have to be able to protect each other
and it does mean something I'm not
saying that it justifies his love for
her but you have to protect each other
and being married legally especially
when kids are involved mean something
well would you owe me something legally
something yeah yeah right right
it does make you question like okay well
how long because I'm grown AF now so if
you're dating new today I'm not if you
so much as asked me to do your laundry I
better be a ring because we are talking
about situation ship so you have like if
you it's about if it's not about jewels
and Kimbella
I want somebody wasn't mellow it's a
deep sigh tradition I really felt I
wanted to wait until I'm saying I and
gently so I understand both sides of the
coin I understand waiting I understand
all of that I just understand the things
that can happen if you don't take care
of your business
ring well we don't know what that man
was going through yeah that made him
feel like now is the best time so like I
so mean like listen
yeah consumption is what he's going
through it they know better you know no
better time than the present time yeah
rice I don't what a problem we should be
congratulating black man marrying his is
the mother of his kid
we tap the nerves and I'm really glad
because that makes me notice you guys
are really into it
yeah because the question is why are we
so scared of commitment I am Sasha K
tweeted marriage is too much of a
commitment but kids aren't make it make
sense
all right let's unpack it yes so guys
you are already way into it but we were
so you were about to make a point about
why you think that situation ships or
couples who are together and have
children together but maybe aren't
married is not something that we should
be looking down upon I think that the
marriage should be the icing on the cake
I think in too many cases people get
married before they really get to know
each other really get to understand each
other and people get married for all the
wrong reasons because just for the sake
of being married oh I got a ring I'm
married right but at the same time if
the [ __ ] was a nasty [ __ ] before you
before you married him you're gonna be a
nasty [ __ ]
after that like the person is the person
like I believe that you should be moving
in a married situation you should really
feel married and allowed the ceremony to
be the icing on the cake well I guess
the question that posted that is why do
you think so many people seem to be more
comfortable having children which i
think is also a commitment that we
should think that much about then
getting married they're insane
everything he just said is correct and
act kids to that you shouldn't act kids
prior to marriage because you do have to
take time to get to know each other with
jewels and Kimbella I don't know how old
they are but they've been together a
long time
so they probably got together when they
were really young so in the case of
being super young yes get to know each
other I don't think ten years is a long
time were that young that's a phone you
hit 3540 you know who you are
you know what you are you know what yeah
so the commitment time is different from
that perspective but you you shouldn't
you should wait and also I will add kids
to that so many people think marriage
equals love and that's not I don't I
totally agree
no you're fine I think what the
situation is that people go through
preliminary years right with a date and
you could date but if you don't know
yourself or that should go out the
window once you like get in a situation
where y'all are no longer playing
boyfriend and girlfriend and y'all are
actually dating for the sake of this
there's a purpose behind it that's when
the real [ __ ] come in because we could
date from 19 to 24 if I don't know
myself we're not paying bills together
we ain't never had no pregnancy scares
nothing like that right it's not real
its preliminary yourself it takes over
exactly to really know yourself know
someone else and through a point you you
you are who you are but there is a
period of growth - that was ten years
ago is totally different than who I
write so that time need that time needs
to happen before the marriage yeah right
it shouldn't be okay I'm feeling you
let's get married and then you find out
who the person is later on that's a very
just for the title going back to the
tweet that is talking about why people
feel like they can have children as how
to be married is because I don't think
people necessarily think that children
is a tie to your partner what matters
right
which is why yes yeah but absolutely
yeah but I think I think it speaks to
kind of a a bigger thing that although
somebody wants to have somebody that is
a descendant of them that does not mean
anyone also be in a partnership but I
don't know if that's if were to say that
that's wrong ya know what I mean like I
don't think yeah I do think we need to
also I mean let's put Mary the marriage
partner side right because you all are
making great points but there's even an
especially now the problem between
getting from dating and talking and to
calling each other boyfriend and
girlfriend right
I think there's I mean even at every
step it seems to be much more spread out
and I think
there are trust issues that a lot of
people have not addressed within
themselves
yeah I don't know if it's because our
generation watched our parents split up
in the way where you know a lot of
people like romanticize their
grandparents because our parents would
have to watch divorce happen as much as
we are but there's something there
that's like scaring us right to
committing the people Russ that's
consistent over time so if you're not
taking that time to get to know
someone's consistency then you're you're
doomed from the door yeah you should
take more time with yourself with the
other person and make sure that you're
on the same page right and then yeah
anyone could be lying but you'll find
that out you can't live forever
yeah but I'm telling you this agree I
don't think it's parents I think the
bigger reason as to why people don't
wanna be relationships has so much more
to do with Society
okay I think that we just think that
there is always something else and
there's always something more and I
think that I don't know very much but I
think it's easy to say but I think I
think that day when my parents are
divorced so I that's why but no it's
that you're able to see the world in
your fingertips and yeah widen your
hunger tips are I think that means the
options also are and that isn't a trip a
friend I would love to hear this there
we go
what's the statistics on marriage that's
wise
I mean boy boy stratum right both
marriages and more marriages in divorce
in divorce right yeah all we meant to be
with one person see that's that's it no
boy are we meant to be with one person
my life not a race I don't want to get
too hot no you ready I don't want to go
too deep about what I've ran women got
eggs listen mister can you can you be my
boys long family and people are like oh
I'm were dating monogamously and nothing
that's been just why are you so afraid
to marry man made marriage is also very
men may know what you're saying and
medicines I can get it out yet are we
made to be married I'm thinking about
the Bible and first Corinthians okay
you're meant to be on the same page okay
so hear me out then so are we really
meant to be with one person that that
that attraction that we all feel for
each other you a man to feel attraction
for 10 different women in this room he
can be attracted to 10 different women
women can be attracted to 10 different
men but they suppress it a lot more
that's the right so I read some that
says humans we like animals the constant
we marry but yeah the concept of
marriage is more man-made right we're
not meant to be monogamous but we
suppress we suppressing our natural not
your vagina whoa that's why I'm like we
should press are not natural and I
disagree but I try to go along your line
in lining you I've never been attracted
to to developers
we're meant to be married the rest of
the privates agree but my question is
though then why do men still want that
expectation from women because a lot of
men want girlfriends privileges but wait
till you hit him that we can all be
attracted simply wonders man responds
about I agree with what you're saying us
literally as sapiens like everything
that we believe is man-made whether it's
from marriages schools everything so I
do agree that I have always believed
that relationships are less about love
and more about choice so even though you
may be attracted to ten woman in the
room right you're you're kind of
suppressing that primal instinct yeah
say five shoes you at this perfect
society standards right but you're in
society Society said that we supposed to
be one person we supposed to love this
one person and married Emma stay with
them forever
but is that realistic why do men cheat
why why to make I have the best woman in
the world everything other [ __ ] why
is there is there what a hundred percent
single or is there honey I'm sorry
100% man that is 100% lawyer do some
okay Jimmy let me let you go because you
behind it say something you go back to
the concept of marriage I mean you you
you got to go back to like the beginning
of time we're talking about partnership
people was getting married because they
family had two llamas and then I had two
llamas and we came together have four
llamas so it wasn't necessarily love cuz
I figured like that's a bacchanal know
he had dog
[Applause]
is that good do it when I'm saying it
relationship aspect came on a
partnership not necessarily love so now
that you bring love into the equation I
just I can't let you go with this
because honestly marriage actually began
about more so ownership it was about a
man owning a woman more than it was a
man running with the woman had right
well I'll give you thinking about like
hammy rabbis code and stuff like that it
was about like what a woman meant and
how like having that woman also elevated
you well he owned a llama and one so
we're talking too much about marriage
here's the thing with that a man right
I'm a geese I'm gonna give you
understand and a man can allow you my
girlfriend see my girlfriend - that's my
girlfriend - you see
that's his natural instinct that it is
hard for him to suppress men we we fall
victim to our lower desire so many times
why you think all men get caught
cheating famous men rich men or man it
wasn't fakes are you in the [ __ ]
white house like come on like I'm trying
to give you with the game do you think
that all men cheat then hmm yes hmm
yes so I understand what you're saying
and as women a lot of times we
marginalize what men are saying and just
go that's immature or you can't say that
but we want them to be sensitive to our
periods or PMS and and things that they
may not understand so let's just
understand what he's trying to say being
honest with a virus from a man that has
access now this is like women don't know
broke man right the local plumber guys
whatever but to check this out so a man
man
he'll try to get llamas it's like put
your llamas together the temptation in a
man that a man deal with on an honor
with you about it is the maturity level
of it and a man growing to a place where
they go I've been there been there done
that heard that a man's love is
practical right so I know you love me if
you if your instinct is to go I want to
make sure you're all right right now is
this attraction in this cheating
physical based or is it saying I want to
take care of her
I want to take care of her knows when
it's mostly physical it's mostly
physical that change you and I for the
man as you get older right especially if
you have a woman in your life that has
that understanding that can work with
you on your man instincts the way you
should be working with me my woman is
things yesterday will grow that is true
to a place where that's not what you
saying anymore no no it takes time and
you're going to catch some [ __ ] it takes
you got to catch some [ __ ] you said
though seriously I think it's really
dangerous how we continue to normalize
what cheating I think we see it as
weakness
I'm trying to give you to know your
thoughts the truth but okay can we
accept cheating yes accept it I'm trying
to get you a understanding right but
that says I change me but should we
accept it if you're saying all men cheat
you're very you're normalizing this
betrayal yeah he also agrees I'm not
saying they can't grow and grow we have
to wait for they grow there before we do
that man you know yeah what you but
that's up to you you have enough did you
feel like you gotta check this out let's
be real that is every woman is going
through this the same thing with
different men like this [ __ ] didn't did
every why are you all through this I
have you guys
according to mein of logic we've all
been cheated on but do you feel like
you've never had a relationship where
you weren't cheated on everybody except
for me no cuz I wasn't I'm pretty sure I
had a relationship well I mean I think
you've not cheated in a relationship how
about how about what not cheap you heard
her okay you're the anomaly that he fain
doesn't exist that no I'm not saying I'm
not saying man see it's like what she
gotta listen what she said men can grow
I'm in a relationship now yeah it every
day it's a it's a fight with you tation
it's a it's that last thing this is no
and I'm not trying to take it there but
do you guys watch the show Atlanta the
show
okay I realize that situation chips are
very much so a thing that thrives in the
black community as well cuz Atlanta is
the only show i'veseen where you see
like earn and his girl you're like well
what are they we understand that but you
don't really see any show that don't
have like black people in them in the
situation like that it's like either
they are broken up they talk or they
don't but we're always trying to figure
out well what are earning his girl and
that's because I think we see that so
much within our community I don't know
any person not of color that is in like
just a random situation ship like that I
really don't they weren't like [ __ ]
all five well I do I'm a question their
situation ships could be healthy for
each other I think that there's a time
and place for them by do they have an
expiration date situation they weren't
doing that on telling us I'm like Ross
and Rachel every now and then maybe but
you didn't see that our oil that earned
his girl had Oh cuz I had a child it was
I mean yeah I get it
I guess you know there is there any
advice that week oh you are you know I
mean I've been in both oh you know where
are you looking for love yes would you
like to be
I did my last relationship was like
three years long you know but I've also
been single now for a few years and I
think part of that was coming out and
seeing like oh [ __ ] nobody is really
doing relationships anymore and I think
that's the scary thing were a lot of men
to your point like what you're saying
it's something that men understand about
men but don't give that same courtesy
the women they want to be able to
understand they can see everybody and
want everybody but they want a woman who
is not doing the same thing they want
all of their said girlfriends to just be
their girlfriends while they have
multiple unhealthy situation ships
situations and I think that we all need
to learn how to recognize them and how
to get out of them when they're I don't
think that I don't know what a healthy
situation ship is I think there's dating
where you're dating multiple people's
houses but I don't think that you're in
a relationship where there's multiple
people my situation ships aren't wrong
some women I have women told me that I
don't want to be your girlfriend
yeah times we would romance by trying to
make everything should be a situation
ship and I think that we're in a place
where a lot of times everything like
people are going from situation to
situation ship the situation ship and
never generate a situation ship until
you're not that's an incident you know
what I mean like what you're doing on
both hands
so we do have move on because even the
best yeah we have gone but no because
everybody just like us everybody on
Twitter thinks their relationship expert
so we're going to examine a few tweets
to see if folks are preaching or
reaching
[Music]
did not create merit no ok so the first
tweet is from those of fat who said
[ __ ] think you can't handle a
no-strings-attached situation [ __ ] when
it's really them who end up catching
feelings
Jameer is she preaching or reaching
she preaching i think a situation or
though like i've know people who have
been in situation ships and they like be
out here and then the girl be like oh i
got a man and then i gotta hear that
your shorty don't want to be with you no
more cuz she actually found a man so I
think it's preaching but it's reaching
if she's talking about wide-scale
because some people be like oh okay
Vaughn do you agree I think she's
reaching because is that sounds like a
tweet to me worse a girl trying to be
cool like a dude like cut it out you
headed out where apples and oranges men
and women are different we have to
accept those differences and stop trying
to be like the dudes are be like how you
are and find the right person reach for
you by not [ __ ] round of applause
okay this is oh who tweeted if you take
the ring off the marriage don't count
may know that if a [ __ ] named STIs oh I
can't even take do you think men see
their men out there who feel like them
the ring is more sober but then like
this if you take the ring I got a
problem a day I probably would have a
problem with that that's a reach
Taylor reach reach reach you there you
ready you got the ring on a night you
burst up the rings would stay on but I
can't even entertain that tweet it's
yeah only if you gotta Jim what's eatin
some people wear the ring while there
she is I mean that's like the hell for
those missiles I tell you why accounts
try to get a divorce and see what
happens in court no matter if you got
your ring on or not when it comes down
to that yes either finally D Rene
tweeted yes I'd like to speak to God
please the men
effective when will we get when will the
new models arrive we have a crisis here
yes I'll hold
Taylor is she preaching her reaching by
blaming our relationship issues on the
fellas I was going to say she's
preaching but this is my caveat okay I
think that both men and women yes have
issues yes I agree I think we probably
need a new wave of both and we get so
caught unlike the blaming the men that
we don't reflect on ourselves and I
think that's probably the bigger issue
so I think she's right but I think
there's another tweet there's nothing
hello hello humans been on reserve
that's a fact like yeah that's all a
father was a [ __ ] right well speaking
of [ __ ]
Jameer and Mae no can defend the fellas
it's time for men are trash
[Music]
[Applause]
as you can see the fellas are on their
trash cans and they each get 60 seconds
to defend this week's trash ass man and
his statement are you ready
Marcus this week's case is from Marcus
of Love & Hip Hop Hollywood not New York
like made no but Hollywood said what
women shouldn't be fully independent if
they want to get a man it's what he said
on Instagram
Jameer your first you have 60 seconds on
the clock to defend that statement go
all right look I'm gonna do my best
Hey look what the brother was trying to
say today if you want to protect God if
you want somebody who is gonna show to
the home put food on the table tops
what's clothes on your back and a raise
the child with you on many depend on you
to weigh in tonight
then you should invest in a man who's
gonna do that now I don't told you drew
what everything the brother was saint
but he wants to make sure that he is the
the the top of the totem poles and
everything else besides a little lower
nothing you on the ground but just
saying dad hey I got it
the whole thing was a guy I and if
that's wrong
what is [ __ ] Sylvia I don't want to be
right you got anywhere just be [ __ ]
all right interesting tactics switching
up what you say all right may know it's
your turn to defend Marcus you have 60
seconds go well III can't defend that
okay I think everything that my my view
my view with that when it comes to that
I'm more attracted to strong females I'm
attracted to independent woman I'm
attracted to that a lot of I don't I
don't know what he was saying but I
noticed that like a lot of a lot of men
like they really be weak in character so
they attracted to the women that they
feel like need them because it makes
them feel better I'm more attracted to
the woman that has her own I like when a
woman I like the woman that I don't need
you [ __ ] I like that because that to me
attracts me more because then it's right
if I get hurt feels better to me that's
just what I like that's just my personal
preference I once more I like what I
like I like strong women you like you
like you like on bills no man has ever
taken which is not actually defending
what's a man's bag lady what do you
think about what the market says I will
say first off hats off to you thank you
the berries berries this far Jumeirah
there is the clip of share that I always
think of or somebody is talking her
about having a man and she says you know
my mom would always say you know share
you need to settle down find yourself a
rich man and sheriff says mom I am a
rich man yeah okay and that's how I feel
when I am going into relationship let me
just say I love men I love loving a man
I love being in love I love being in a
relationship I love being in a
partnership people talk about finding
your other half and finding somebody
that complete to you but I am out
looking for a half because I am already
home I'm looking for somebody who was
also home I go let's not make you feel
whole is to make you feel more full and
sometimes that comes with being
independent I'm going to have your back
I am going to take care of you I'm going
to make sure that you are always good
and I want the same in return so if we
are both independent we are both whole
then that should be fine I'm not look
for any man to say to me like you're too
independent you make too much money
you're because that man is not for me
yeah I think that men sometimes want to
look for someone who is submissive and I
will submit when it is right when I
respect you when I trust you when I feel
that we are there but we're not always
there we have to grow there so that is
my only rebuttal to what he said I can
be independent and still love you with
my whole entire heart and that's what I
have done my whole life yes Vaughn
you're so I would like to also hats off
and say I don't I'm a dominant woman I'm
a dominant woman that likes to be
submissive to a more dominant man you
know what I'm saying
and for the the trash of it okay
[Applause]
can I get a 60 second but what I want to
say to Marcus and his statement is this
I guess Barack and Michelle did it wrong
I guess Beyonce and jay-z are doing it
right compliment each other
I was already uncomfortable letting our
strong this strong man the patient's
must pay for their privilege every now
and then I feel but this attic and I
feel you you know where's my sight you
won't talk about big in the perm and
before we head out I have some things I
need to get off my chest and it includes
big in that black man so let's see Cretu
and all of the men who were in it
shirtless because a thirst trap perfect
specimen of a man right when he made
first the first free then somebody who
deserves a damn it he did that too and
then you know shout out the Tessa
Thompson who was a dream in the film as
well I loved watching her and Michael B
Jordan together as a couple so much I
kind of want them to give me a little
rock on or something like that then
finally Russell Hornsby who was in
everything was in this movie I almost
probably got he was gonna be in it but
somebody give that man an Oscar just for
working so damn hard yeah you gave seven
seconds and Cretu he's been killing it
this year and that is my big up for
Blackmon at the end black man thank you
all for joining us all of you guys were
great I had a great time talking to all
of you I'm Sylvia LaBelle tune in here
next Wednesday at 9 p.m. Eastern for all
new hella opinion
[Music]